um
you know one thing i'll say is that
when i look back at what happened the
one thing i wish i did less of was the
drugs yeah the drugs did not enhance
things they
corrupted a lot of things and they made
a lot of memories like really
far less enjoyable and colorful than
they should have been for example i've
fallen asleep in the finest restaurants
in the world
i got booked for a speech in the next
month in monaco right yeah and they've
got a beautiful suite at the hotel de
right and i was like oh yeah i fell
asleep at the louis 14th restaurant in
the bowl of soup and they you know it's
twelve thousand dollar dinner i can't
remember it but i remember it was total
bread and i felt my wife had to pick my
head up out of the freaking soup right
so like that was like the story of my
life so that aspect i look back and say
i wish i could have you know done things
differently with the drugs
yeah i i want to back up to say you said
before about the government because it
was it was making me think of wolf wall
street so the thing about the movie i
mean the movie's so freaking brilliant i
won't make you talk about it because
you've talked about it a bajillion times
but you know you base you're the hero of
the movie obviously and yet you're also
doing some illegal [ __ ] you're doing
some moral [ __ ] or however you want to
describe it
but you hate the feds more you hate the
people going after you more and they're
supposed to be the good guys right
because you're doing stuff with the
penny stocks or whatever it is and that
i think sort of captures what you said
about the government before like they've
done so much stuff now that it's sort of
like the sopranos you're never rooting
against tony he's killing people and
you're still rooting for him does that
tell you something about how backwards
everything is in an odd way i think that
the lines
of right and wrong morality have been
very much blurred i think people just
realize for example it's just my case
specifically like people know that like
what i did
was nothing compared to what they did in
goldman sachs and and merrill lynch and
these guys bankrupted iceland and greece
it almost took down the entire world
economy
and and no one went to jail like at
least i went to jail for a couple of
years and did my time and like i had to
pay the price i had to rebuild my life
like that was like a thousand times
worse doesn't mean that riding was right
but but people also saw like there's
like this sort of you know i think
people like the almost the tortured soul
type like like i'm like you're watching
me walk off the edge why you stopped
though like you know so you see there
was goodness in me there was
misguidedness in me and and i think
people like that complexity and you
could root for someone who i think you
feel like genuinely they're almost their
own worst enemy they're not killing
people and even by the way with tony
what's tony you can root for tony too
but like in this case i'm not killing
people but you're saying why why and i
think people can see themselves
in a lot of the of the characters in
that type of movie and that's scorsese's
brilliance by the way
like he doesn't moralize he just puts
characters up that are actually real and
complex and you're watching good people
do bad things in bed and and people that
are you know all terrible people do good
things when you look back on all that
like are you just like even when you
post pictures a lot of times on
instagram you'll post pictures of of
what you were doing back then you know
30 years ago like what you were actually
doing like are you like man that was
just freaking great even though how long
were you in jail for 22 months
so all right that was a terrible job a
little more than jesse but yeah
another character right um
you know one thing i'll say is that
when i look back at what happened
the one thing i wish i did less of was
the drugs yeah the drugs did not enhance
things they corrupted a lot of things
and they made a lot of memories like
really
far less enjoyable and colorful than
they should have been for example i've
fallen asleep in the finest restaurants
in the world
i got booked for a speech in the next
month in monaco right and they got a
beautiful suite at the hotel de berry
right and i was like oh yeah i fell
asleep at the louis 14th restaurant in
the bowl of soup and then you know it's
twelve thousand dollars did i can't
remember it but i remember it's all
bread and i thought my wife had to pick
my head up out of the freaking soup
right so like that was like the story of
my life so that aspect i look back and
say i wish i could have you know done
things differently with the drugs um but
other than that you know when i look at
it you know i wouldn't change anything
because it was my it was like what got
me to this point in my life obviously i
made some mistakes i had a lot of fun
did a lot of things right as well uh but
i think looking back at your life and
trying to say i shouldn't have done that
i don't think it's healthy what do you
think
kept you going like that you're not
broken now like you're so thriving it's
every time i'm around you and everyone
knows it like you're infectious with
your energy this is exactly who you are
off the camera like you just freaking
love life like what
did you ever get to a point where you
were like starting to break or anything
like that yeah of course i did i mean i
think that you know um the worst part
was before i went to jail
it's like you're dying in slow motion
and that's like where you know you
because you know you're going and you
can't restart your life and you know
it's like you know it's like it was like
i lived in the big house still then
taking it's like roam fly the falling
empire of rome like you're watching the
house collapse or everything collapse
around me right
um
you know for me
the amount of pride that i took in
rebuilding my life ethically i can't
tell you like what that meant to me to
go out and prove to myself to my
children
that was really not the world to my
children that that like that i would
just go out right again and just do
things so straight as an arrow and
empower people all over the world and
make even more money and like to me that
was like and that just like was like
something that just kept me going in the
early days and it just snowballed it's
fed in itself and fed in itself and um
yeah my life today is far better than it
ever was back in the craziest times of
strand yeah that's got to be a crazy
retraining right to try to do things
fully on the up and up we were going to
try to do something and i have a feeling
we'll do something in the future but
even when we were in the little
negotiations and then things just moved
too fast you were basically like just
give me something and i'll make it work
like you didn't want to negotiate you
were just like let's make it nice and
easy and then things just happen right
so move along in a different way but
like was that a real shift for you like
how you're going to do business like
actually how you're going to engage in
that
so
yes and no i think one of the lessons i
learned was that
if you're a really good negotiator right
and negotiate a deal where it's so great
for you and badly other people that's
not a good negotiation it just ends up
in a lawsuit ak steve madden shoes like
when steve came to me he was very young
he was naive and i took his company from
him legally and i took 85 percent
because he didn't know better and all i
did was created animosity down the road
so i don't think a great negotiation is
when you
get such a good deal you [ __ ] everyone
else over
and also just like i i just i just
refuse to cut corners like in my life my
value system right now is just simply
it's just the it's just based on
creating value of people so i there's a
reason why i haven't that is why you
launch any nfts yet there's a reason why
i haven't launched an empties because
i'm not sure if the market is ready and
i don't know i'll make a quick 10
million yeah but probably people who buy
them might lose a quick 7 million so i
didn't do it i just didn't
i would love to have the extra money but
i have enough money i'm not going to
market
engaging transactions or any business
practices that i'm not giving more value
than i received and frankly i've ended
up making more money because of that
it's my greed shows me if i'm greedy
that means do that give people more
value because you make more in the long
run when you see these insane
policies of just printing money and then
biden comes out oh it has inflation has
nothing to do with printing money and
it's not our fault
like like as a guy who understands
business
you want to punch the screen or what
yeah so mine's an idiot i mean um and i
think everyone knows that he but he's
not he's not even the piece of puppet
yeah i mean it's like it's like the
movie's so bad like it's like dave we're
like let's [ __ ] great movie where can we
find someone so stupid and so malleable
and just so much of a puppet like here
we go right to be clear you're not
talking about me david there was a movie
dave with uh
kevin
yeah
so
biden
is a total puppet
and everyone everyone knows this you're
not making any decisions right
and um
he says stuff that's just
it's idiotic
it's just it's just it's like patently
false and anyone knows the first thing
about money and economics and the way
the world works
it's like it's just like it's just
silliness and i'm not quite sure why he
says that i would think that people
would coach him better if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell